yes tonight lady gentleman is a writer
on HBO's mr. show and he'll be appearing
at Largo in Hollywood California on July
27 please welcome a very funny guy
Paul F Tompkins
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen you will
enjoy my portion of the show and I'll
tell you why because I am hammered I
have been drinking since noon today so
it's gonna be great I was all out of my
apartment pretending I was at a wedding
reception just got all dressed up and
started pounding beers that's gonna be
fun but I am baffled by people who are
thrown off by daylight savings time it's
just an hour adjustment twice a year
that's all it's not disorienting but
still twice here you hear people say
stuff like I'm sorry man I'm uh I'm all
screwed up cuz a daylight savings time
if you find yourself saying that you
might as well say I have trouble talking
to people so I just let my mouth open up
and let words fall out of it because
talking is hard with the eye the thing
it it's just an hour there's no need for
what is this milk still good who is the
president now do I have a great bushy
beard now or now I am Irish and growing
up I had to hear stories of the terrible
horrible Irish potato famine of the
$0.18 and how horrible it was now
millions of people died millions why
because there were no potatoes are these
the pickiest people in the world my
belly's distended
I'm dying if only I had a potato
why don't you want you to try some corn
I don't like corn are you sure you
probably never even tried it oh yeah
remember at that party they had corn I
tried it then don't care for it no no
well you got it you got to do something
just have some corn I have a problem
with textures you know some things feel
weird in my mouth and corns just kind of
gross well okay just go ahead and starve
to death
uh well that's what I was doing before
you had to interview me for your book
about corn that's my favorite part
why why why do people write letters to
magazines I ask you it's pointless
what's the point especially the people
that write letters to Entertainment
Weekly or as I call it Leonardo DiCaprio
daily I am wicked people write letters
to Entertainment Weekly just to say how
much they like the picture on the cover
that's their whole letter that's it what
the hell dear Entertainment Weekly
thanks so much for putting a picture a
Leonardo DiCaprio on the cover of your
magazine I like him so you can imagine I
was sure pleased to see a picture of
them on the front of your book it is
nice you to put pictures of things I
like on the front part of your magazine
for future reference here's some other
things I like I like Tomatoes tea cozies
some dogs most cats there's a cat in my
neighborhood named speedy I'm awful fond
of maybe you could put a picture of them
on the front part of your book I don't
know if you'd send a photograph or to
take a picture of him or a sketch artist
to draw a picture of them but you better
be quick because they don't call them
speedy for nothing oh well all the
Bloods leave in my head now so I better
sign I love a big dumb jackass
[Applause]